honoré daumier est né à marseille le 27
février 1808 il est le fils de cécile
catherine philippe et de jean baptiste
et de miers vitrier jean baptiste denier
est aussi poète et sa notoriété
naissante l'incitent à s'installer à
paris où sa famille le rejoint en 1816
honorait apprend à dessiner grâce aux
chevaliers lenoir ami et protecteur de
son père les lithographies techniques
nouvelles commencent à révolutionner la
presse daumier entre chez le lithographe
marseillais belliard juillet 1830 la
révolution éclate le peuple envahi paris
avec l'aide de l'armée
charles 10 abdique pour empêcher la
proclamation de la russie ont fait appel
au duc de pire et on le nomme lieutenant
général du royaume
ainsi avoir une république et n'est une
monarchie parlementaire il est vrai le
duc d'orléans sera donc louis philippe
1er mai la monarchie de juillet devra
compter avec une nouvelle forme
d'opposition
la caricature et son maître une heure et
demie et l'opposition se manifestent
immédiatement et avec une très grande
activité
les insurrections sont fréquentes dans
paris et elles ont une raison économique
en ce sens que le peuple est malheureux
les ouvriers sont en chômage
il n'y a pas des compensations comme de
nos jours
et de toute évidence on a faim par
conséquent les révoltes sont assez
fréquentes et les répressions et parfois
sévères et dur aussi certains journaux
d'opposition manifeste cette opposition
avec une immense virulence charles
philippon qui vient de créer un journal
qui s'appelle la caricature engage un
certain nombre de jeunes artistes
caricaturiste et rédacteur et tout ce
sont dans cette même ligne d'opposition
et de contestation parmi eux la se
distingue assez vite c'est un an et demi
non
oui
à
déjà condamné à six mois de prison avec
sursis ce pour salif graphique gargantua
la publication des blanchisseurs
entraîne l'arrestation de deniers il se
retrouva salle pélagie rejoints bientôt
par filippo
avec le règne de louis-philippe c'est
l'irrésistible ascension de la
bourgeoisie
de miers et philippe on projette de
créer un nouveau journal le charivari
ce journal devenu le symbole de
l'indépendance et de la liberté
d'expression paraîtra jusqu'au début du
20e siècle
alors que le roi se rend au bourget un
postillon est blessé louis-philippe le
saut en pratique en lui l'âme une
saignée ce geste lui vaudra la grande
médaille de la vertu et une lithographie
de daumier ses lithographies qui font
sourire n'en sont pas moins des actes
j'en alliés de position régime
il en est d'autres plus sanglant en 1834
des émeutes éclatent à lyon puis à paris
violemment réprimées c'est le massacre
de la rue trans nona une lithographie
féroce et bouleversante accueillis avec
émotion par les opposants au régime
près de 200 inculpés sont jugés en cour
d'assises
daumier assister aux séances de la
chambre des pairs et il faisait en
rentrant ensuite ces bustes que nous
avons ici il ne semble pas qu'il ait
fait des croquis au crayon thomas on ne
connaît pas mais il a tout de même fait
des portraits d'après ces séances
puisqu'il a été un peu plus tard un
véritable reporter un chroniqueur
judiciaire en assistante aux différents
procès où il a fait les portraits des
juges et les portraits des accusés dans
le cas présent ces bustes lui ont été
commandés par philippon en 1832
philippon ce journaliste de génie
toujours à l'affût de ce qui pouvait
donner quelques actualités à son journal
la caricature demanda daumier de faire
ces bustes et ceci est annoncée à
plusieurs reprises dans le journal
daumier fait donc ses bustes en terre
crue et colorier et il apparaît bien que
il était dans les bureaux du journal est
servi de modèles non seulement à lui
tourisme et aux autres caricaturistes et
on peut trouver des traits semblables
dans les caricatures des autres
dessinateurs semblables à ceux de
daumier parce que le portrait
caricaturer doit être un portrait
déformée mais surtout reconnaissables
par conséquent les caricaturistes
différents ne peuvent pas chacun faire
des caricatures ou des portraits
nettement différents les uns des autres
le très important de la caricature c'est
que le personnage soit immédiatement
reconnu on sait parfaitement que
louis-philippe sans la musique beaucoup
et les hommes politiques les ont connus
aussi lorsqu'un homme politique est
portraituré il s'en réjouit et on a bien
vu d'ailleurs à différents moments que
certains se plaignaient d'être délaissée
autrefois comme d'ailleurs ils se
plaignent encore aujourd'hui d'être
délaissée aussi par certains
caricaturistes
ça fait partie de l'occupation et de la
notoriété de l'homme politique d'être
très fréquemment montré dans les dessins
aujourd'hui c'est la télévision qui lui
montre pierre à la suite de manoeuvres
subtil et plus ou moins délicate est
nommé président du conseil journalistes
une istres historien homme d'état de par
ses fonctions son caractère et son
physique tiers ne peut échapper à
l'ironie de daumier
le aux comptes cochard et paris était
tiré à 3000 exemplaires mais étaient
3000 exemplaires qui est élu chacun par
un très grand nombre de personnes lui ai
vu surtout parce que l'image tous les
jours la caricature de chaque jour était
diffusé on se la passer en la commenter
on l'étudié à la veillée et on l'a
reproduisait et bien ce charivari avait
donc un très très grand rayonnement et
il est évident que toutes ces
caricatures politiques avaient un impact
très réel le 28 juillet 1835 la machine
infernale mise en place sur le passage
du cortège royal par pièce qui m'aurait
et pepa fonctionne faisant 18 morts et
de nombreux blessés
louis philippe est indemne il fait voter
les lois de septembre parmi lesquels la
loi infernal restreignant la liberté de
la presse et visant tout
particulièrement la représentation par
l'image les caricatures politiques ne
peuvent plus paraître le charivari
survie pendant 13 ans demi et publie des
séries les bons bourgeois les gens de
justice les plaideurs à travers ses
personnages
il se moque des bourgeois donc du régime
celui ci est devenu trop absolue et
c'est finalement la réforme électorale
et parlementaire qui va déclencher la
seconde révolution de ce siècle
on est en république
il n'y a plus de raison d'être méchant
ni d'être acerbes contre les hommes du
pouvoir
ce sont les républicains qui sont en
place par conséquent tous les hommes
politiques qui sont maintenant au début
au début en place sont des jeunes dirait
patrick dom et de ceux qui sont
sympathiques ou sympathisants de sorte
que l'un des taux de cette période sont
des lithos amusante humoristique il y à
une série qui s'intitule les idylles
parlementaire elle comprend 16
lithographies dans lesquelles les hommes
politiques sont montrés dans le plus
simple appareil à peu près nulles et
dans des scènes bucoliques
c'est extrêmement amusant et c'est plein
d'esprit
la république est fragile demi est mieux
que tout autre pressant et traduit les
intrigues qui se nouent autour du
prince-président il donne naissance à
ratapoil personnage à la solde des
bonapartistes symboles de la corruption
électorale ratapoil rêve à l' empire
berrier légitimiste regrette les
bourbons tiers arbitre
il se tient prêt à pencher du côté du
plus fort
ce sera lempire le coup d'état du 2
décembre 1851 une conséquence dramatique
le muselage de la presse une fois encore
dominer n'est plus libre de s'exprimer
il faudra attendre 18 ans la chute de
l'empiré pour revoir ses productions
publiés en attendant la bourgeoisie a
retrouvé la sérénité
oh
on
une nouvelle série de lithographies nous
fait découvrir daumier visionnaire le
danger cette fois vient de l'extérieur
la politique du bismarck l'armement la
guerre imminente
oh
mon
inébranlable dans ses convictions
républicaines lucides courageux daumier
a su capter et même prévoir les craintes
et les désirs ses contemporains une
carte d'électeur c'est pour daumier
l'aboutissement de 42 années de lutte et
d'espoir honoré daumier s'éteint en 1879
il y a tout juste un siècle
où
le